i used to do this thing called crank
texting where i would just text
strangers like just text random phone
numbers yeah
and i would just say hey what's up right
yeah and then i get into a conversation
sometimes and somebody would think i was
an old friend or something hey is this
randall and it's like yeah i haven't
heard from you in a while and then
next thing you know i'm asking if i can
come stay the night and it's like you
know i'm in this
crazy conversation that makes no sense
right it's not even real yeah
like i was in relationships with people
like oh bro crazy stuff
crazy stuff so i mean i texted probably
about 40 000 numbers over a couple of
year period you seriously did i was so
lonely i would text
i would text back this is when you were
on the road or you were just you were
just doing this
this is all the time did you bring up
crank text nick this was all the time
um i would just start texting strangers
yeah i just got into it and sometimes i
would
uh just text just a group of people you
know just cranktext.com
um do you renew this
domain every year i think so
let's just see if it's still uh
so obviously it needs to be adjusted
here for the screen somehow
but yeah you get into different
conversations like i would text people
in a certain area code like in indiana
and i'd be like we're raising money for
uh civil war reenactments after school
team right
and you get into real conversations
people start leaving your voicemails and
next thing you know you have this whole
conversation then you can take it
and you post it in here right so you
getting a like you know this one was one
i would text thank you for
what's that the hellman's one thank you
for entering the love your helmets
contest we'll be contacting you once the
judges have reviewed all
entries good luck and thank you for
loving your helmets
so you just send that to strangers and
people like what in the [ __ ] you talking
about dude
or you send them a picture you know oh
hellman's man
and then they have to reply just so you
anyway but anyway i got into insane
conversations i would text a group of
people
and i would be like oh ricky won third
place and i would get a picture of an
asian kid with a trophy and just send it
to all of them in a mass text right
and so somebody would be like who's
ricky right and somebody would like take
me off this chain
right and somebody would be like oh
bless his heart man
and then somebody else would be like who
in the [ __ ] is this
man and i'd be like if some of you guys
cared if you had been there you'd
if you cared more you'd have been there
to see him win right yeah so anyway i
get in this crazy conversation with
people
and i would just save and put them
online anyway fast forward that was your
idea
right that was my idea right this was
probably a decade ago so howie mandel
was looking for somebody to host
a prank show yeah so i had done this
for years man i'd spend a ton of money
paying people to edit them up
um spend a ton of time a ton of time
and he's like oh i like your prank
website
and so that's how i got a job hosting
his prank show
so he saw it he saw it yeah and so it
was like
i'd spent all this time doing it and it
wasn't
getting anywhere yeah i just didn't have
the pr to make it pop
and uh and then it got me a job on his
show and it was it wasn't
it was you know it wasn't like my type
of show really but i was a great
opportunity it gave me enough money
where i was able to then to pay back the
comedy debt that i built up
yeah and you also have a relationship
with howie and now i still have a
relationship with him yeah which is
great so
which then introduced me he got me on to
like arsenio hall one time to perform
just little things so it's just like you
just don't know what what you're doing
now where it could end you up mm-hmm
sometimes yeah
that yo and when you give up on that
it's it's gone or when you stray off
that path
yeah you know i mean and go off into a
different direction if your heart
isn't that way it's nothing's gonna
happen
right yeah your heart has to be there
though your heart has to be here and
whether
no matter how bad the struggle is as
long as your heart
is there things will have i i keep
saying that like
every time i go on this road something
just
just comes into in into my path
it just it just happens you know what i
mean and and then next you know what
this relationship
starts and next you know i'm building
this and now i'm writing this and
and that's what it is it's just staying
here man once you give up and stray off
like if i would have became a manager
like my mom wanted me to be
i i'd be at wells fargo going hey man uh
let me tell you this one joke that i got
you're gonna love this one let's go god
here comes that manager guys here he
comes again
here comes zinger he's always got a
pocket full of zingers
when i was living in my car i started a
website
because they just released this thing on
nfl.com it was called the all 22 cam so
you could actually see the place because
you can't see that on tv you can see
what safeties are doing and i wanted to
break down the x's and o's and i bought
a website called packersfilmroom.com
and i didn't know what i was doing but i
learned how to build a website and i was
living in my car so like 150
for a domain at that time was a
significant amount of money and
it went for nothing it didn't do
anything but i learned how to build a
website and a bunch of that stuff when i
got hired at corolla
i immediately started doing some of that
stuff for them and i just learned it
yeah yeah so at that time it was a scary
investment but you were so
your heart was in it yeah that that
thank god you did that
because it gave you the the tools that
you needed when you did
get the opportunity right doing doing
something is always better than doing
nothing
i guess what we're trying to say is risk
you have some risk there's risk takers
like there's risk takers yeah
but also you don't know what the things
you've been doing where that
those elements are going to be needed
yeah or when that value is going to pay
off yes
you just don't know when that value is
going to pay off sometimes man good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah